6 % c'est la part des travailleurs
handicapés que les entreprises de plus
de 20 salariés doivent embaucher une
obligation légale qui date de 1987
pourtant dès les années 70 une loi
prévoyait déjà un quota de 10 % mais il
était loin d'être respectée j'ai été
reçu par la sncf
dans un premier temps tout s'est bien
passé mais à l'issue d'un second
entretien ayant remarqué que j'étais
handicapé on m'a refusé le droit de
passer les tests comme tous les gens qui
étaient en même temps que moi et
aujourd'hui où en sont les entreprises
pour respecter le quota fixé par la loi
plusieurs alternatives s'offrent à elle
recruter des personnes handicapées en
emploi direct employer au moins un
travailleur handicapé et ou avoir
recours à la sous traitance ou conclure
un accord agréé avec l'état en 2010 est
un rapport révélait que 30 % des
entreprises françaises optait pour la
première option 39 % pour la deuxième et
11% pour la dernière les 20% restants
correspondent aux sociétés qui
n'emploient aucun travailleur handicapé
et qui préfèrent payer une contribution
au fonds dette des handicapés c'était le
cas de ce patron en 1997 on cotise ans
cotisent régulièrement et puis bon ça
devient une
une coutume on sait qu'on a ça a payé
donc on ne va pas chercher plus loin
depuis je le dirai quand on recherche un
poste on n'a pas idée d'aller de se
retourner entre guillemets devant une
personne handicapée face à ce constat
nouvelle loi handicap
en 2005 elle renforce certaines
dispositions de 1987 et oblige par
exemple les employeurs à prendre des
mesures appropriées pour permettre aux
travailleurs handicapés d'accéder ou de
conserver un emploi mais en 2009
ce responsable rh évoqué un autre frein
au recrutement des personnes handicapées
on cherche des bac + 2 et voir plus et
80% des salariés handicapés n'ont pas le
bac donc en fait on charge des moutons à
six pattes et toutes les entreprises
cherchent les mêmes moutons donc au
final c'est vrai qu'il faut pas soin est
omniprésent c'est ce qu'on essaye de
faire soit de créer ses compétences
malgré les lois successives le taux de
chômage des travailleurs handicapés est
encore aujourd'hui de 19 % soit deux
fois plus que le reste de la population
[Musique]